Hãy nhé chăng để sĩ thành phố, đối không tên phường loa bình, đoàn tại biểu gió đồng chỉ trần lưu quan,
với viên bộ chính trị, bí thưa thành uì thành phố hồ chính miếng làm trường loa,
đã đến giang luôn, giang qua, trường nhớ cây hùng để sĩ,
tại đây, các bạn biểu đá dành phút mặc niệm vài toa loa biết ơn sâu sắc với công lau của các mẹ Việt Nam anh cùng,
cây hùng để sĩ những người đã hì sĩ in cho độc lập từ gió của tổ quốc,
và đã biểu thành phố cùng đa đến biểu giang qua, giang luôn, chiến các mẹ Việt Nam anh cùng,
các thế hệ lãng gạo, các bật ló thành kết mà đã có những công viên to lớn trong công cuộc sây dựng và bà về tổ quốc tạnh để chăng thành phố hồ chỉ mình,
tất nhiễn chăng là cạnh, phường lưng xuân, thành phố cũng đã tổ chức các mwan đại biểu đến biểu cây hùng để sĩ tại đây,
tưởng miệm lịch sĩ đến dựng, sã ăn nhìn tay, nghĩa chăng để sĩ của chỉ sã ăn nhìn tay,
nghĩa chăng chính sách thình phố sá phố ở đâu, nhá tưởng miệm mà mẹ Việt Nam anh cùng,
lực lượng của chăng giành dân của anh thì dành, dịt tích lịch sử cấp phúc ra nhà bà dồng xã mà điểm,
đó lành gạo thành phố cũng đã đến biểu giang nè xí dừng sát xác cần giờ,
nè xí bình dường của mình thổng giáo, nè xa là xí bà rẻ cũng tổ quân bà rẻ.